we're living in an age when the precise
opposite is true of almost every claim
you hear in public so it probably
shouldn't shock you that the people who
care the least about the natural world
are self-proclaimed environmentalists
they're happy to wreck it for profit
make the oil companies look like
look like deep environmentalists and if
you doubt that take a look at what's
happening off the east coast of the
United States so-called green ngos
supported of course by the people they
give money to in the bite Administration
are back in the construction of massive
offshore wind turbines that appear to be
killing large numbers of whales in just
the last two months at least 10 dead
whales have washed ashore in New York in
New Jersey and a Monday it happened
again a 35-foot male humpback whale died
and washed up
on Lido Beach in Nassau County in Long
Island Bruce blakeman is the county
executive of Nassau he joins us tonight
Mr blakeman thank you so much for coming
on so this seems this seems like one of
those stories that
since liberals want to save the whales
or did when I was a kid you'd think we'd
be getting an awful lot of attention but
it seems like nobody wants to talk about
it why is that
well first of all I became very
concerned when seven whales washed up on
the shores of New Jersey because
obviously we're just miles from New
Jersey and uh then when I found out
yesterday that a whale had washed up on
our Shores here in Lido Beach in Nassau
County obviously I became concerned
because I know that there is
construction taking place out in the
ocean and I think that when you have so
many of these large animals that wash up
on shore dead that we now have to take a
pause and investigate why is that
happening we've got to find that out
because sea life is an important part of
living in Nassau County we've got whales
we have seals we have dolphins and we've
got tremendous fishing here people move
here because they want to enjoy the
beaches the wildlife and the water so
it's a concern and it Bears
investigation
well I would say and it's it's very odd
considering that if you want to move
your cows into a new pasture in some
rare salamander is found there the
federal government shuts it down they're
very uptight about killing animals
that's not all bad by the way but here
the biggest mammals in the world are
dying in an unexplained way and there's
no curiosity I just think it's the
strangest thing I've ever seen
well yeah you know listen there are a
lot of people that are disingenuous uh
they can't find a balance it's like
talking about going all electric
um that would be a danger to our America
the way that we live uh they'll always
be fossil fuels at least in my lifetime
and certainly alternative energy is
important as well and you have to have
Alternative Energy but the fact of the
matter is there's got to be a balance
and basically there are people who can
never Strike that balance unless it's in
order to their benefit and in in this
case uh I'm quite surprised that there
aren't more environmentalists and
certainly people who are involved in
protecting sea life and animals speaking
out about this and and at least asking
for an investigation as to whether or
not there's any causal relationship
between these whales dying and the
construction and the sonar that's being
used
yeah I mean there are a lot of Americans
who care deeply about the natural world
about the environment but the
professional environmental groups are
prostitutes and shills obviously um if
you're destroying the environment you're
not saving the environment I would say
anyway Bruce blakeman I sure appreciate
your being willing to talk about this in
public the Nassau County Executive thank
you
thank you Tucker
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight